qu'est-ce qu'on allait commencer tir
écouter aujourd'hui n'y a pas de thème
précis aujourd'hui j'ai juste envie de
voir des trucs cool et d'être
impressionné de faire ce fameux au mot
même bien le faire cela devant des
vidéos saut il montre que ce truc que tu
vas voir tu va en parler dans la journée
à un ami devinez quoi il ya un seul
président qui est rempli de ce cas de
figure et s'appelle ben may est alors on
est loin d'un seul vrai dit niche ça
fait cinq ans qu'il existe celui là et
ya plus de 2 millions de membres
autant vous dire que il fait un tabac
sur indices s'il vous plaît ramenons
c'est expression à la mode là il a fait
un tabac avec sa dernière vidéo
j'adorerais que ça revienne à la mode
tout ça s'il vous plaît et réutilisées
faire un terme à mes premiers de grève
vous dédouanez pas de le dire dit le
premier degré comme si rien n'était bref
on commença voilà un exemple parfait
exemple parfait de ce que je dise
l'association marine beach clean up a
retiré plus de 700 tonnes de plastique
de notre plage un point bonus pour le
chien et ses impressionnants déjà que
l'humanité face à ces fous mais qu'elle
soit capable juste derrière de faire ça
c'est quand même très agréable à boire
pas mal tony hawk tony hawk mais
attendez ce mec à quel âge les deux
personnes les plus vieilles de la
planète sont la reine d'angleterre et
tony hawk
excusez moi les gars il fait du skate
depuis si un siècle on a tous torcher le
jeu sur gamecube
le mec depuis encore sur des skates
excusez-moi des tétons et en plus il n'a
pas perdu mais 1% de son level regarder
à 52 ans mais qu'un par solange
achèterait même pas ton jeu ait à tête
sympathique envers ce mec est une force
de la nature je trouve ça impressionnant
52 ans quand tu te blesses le temps
qu'il faut pourtant remettre ces six
fois le temps qu'il faut quant à 20 ans
et ton corps il est censé être un peu
rouillé sur cette plus dur lui rien n'a
bougé
c'est incroyable polir une pièce
ansérienne ils vont m'apprendre à
prendre soin de ma youtube baudet
c'est beaucoup d'efforts pour entretenir
une pièce qui ne lui apporte pas plus de
valeur à des mois que c'est une pièce de
collection peut-être les belles l'achat
vous allez belle attendait la vidéo est
très longue mais regardez la pièce
comment elle est en 4k menant 5 à 20 ans
elle avait cette tête là les pièces à la
base ça a bien changé
maintenant il ya toutes les maladies du
monde dessus un groupe de vaches avec
une attente de toi est ce que c'est bien
ce que j'ai vu
quoi mais quoi une valse et jam à stoke
1 vous avez vu des vaches dans la vraie
vie mais cette vache elle a avalé
d'autres vaches pour devenir lavage
calais old shit acquis en plus dans ses
camarades un adorable cosplay
transformers a trop mignon c'est le rêve
de tout enfant d'avoir pu se transformer
ouah bien solide 10 sur 10 le camion le
camion [ __ ] alors attendez attendez
c'est très stylé mais ce chiot c'est
super d'avoir un pote qui a ce costume
meeddat dans le costume toi tu ne vois
pas le résultat au revoir je tue et à
quatre pattes sur un trottoir
eroglu non je suis je suis aigri je suis
sûr je pense tout de suite au problème
plutôt que de trouver sa juste mais lyon
a peut-être aux allées voir la mère de
son adversaire après l'avoir battu et
lui avoir volé son titre
qu'est ce que tu veux dire à la mer du
gard que tu as battu et dont tu as volé
le titre que moi je peux pas la croiser
autant qu est-ce que c'est au nom il
culpabilise aux messins ferroul ya pas
de souci
nommé et du trek à tout ça mais c'est
incroyable ça ils doivent être copains
les deux combattants ils ont dû
commencer ça se trouve ensemble ce sport
regarder ma gestuelle à quel point je
suis à l'aise avec les sports de combat
avaient vu en vrai c'est intéressant ça
doit être trop bizarre de commencer un
sport de se faire un pote du coup dans
le cours de sport de faire des années
des années avec lui et puis tous les
deux vous arrivez au niveau et puis un
jour vous affrontez quoi sur le ring et
parce que vous êtes tous les deux
devenus trop fort et du coup vous êtes
en compétition ça doit être trop bizarre
comme fils et testé une ampoule de 20
kilowatts
je n'ai aucune idée de ce que ça
représente en termes de puissance et
spain poule sa radio torse et les trucs
rouge là en terrasse qui tiennent chaud
c'est ça on devrait en fait c'est
finalement c'est ce qu'il ya dans une
ampoule mais ces minuscules dans une
ampoule normal vous avez vu la taille
des files
c'est en train de devenir lumineux ça
prend du temps [ __ ] haut
on vient de se faire irradier [ __ ]
merde c'est l'hiver nous mettez pas ça
dans la gueule
ouah mais c'est un coup à je pense que
si tu regardes l'an poule tu as vraiment
des blême à la rétine quoi comme quand
tu regardes le soleil c'est sûr super
dure je veux une fête non mais regardez
comment ça on dirait qu'il ya une
explosion en cours on dirait un
champignon atomique qui se forment ces
ballons mon dessin de ya deux ans et
maintenant
ouais ok pas ou franchement va flex
ailleurs pour voir le record du monde
féminin d' escalade au passage doit être
impressionnant moi je suis en escalade
attention pour m'impressionner faut y
aller alors ça va aller beaucoup plus
vite qu'on ne le pense c'est sûr
regardez bien
[Musique]
ouah ouah elle connaît par coeur c'est
pas possible
wael à désactiver la gravité faut
qu'elle appuie sur la touche insert on
va voir son petit apparaître c'est
incroyable sachez qu'une fois j'ai fait
de l'escaladé j'étais super bon et le
prof m'a dit ah mais c'est parce que tu
étais vraiment hyper léger comme gâtés
un squelette
voilà donc c'était un mauvais profs ça
m'a fait mal au coeur prof escalade je
vous ai maintenant comment faire pour
que ton feutre à table au vide marche de
nouveau serment des cerveaux des vidéos
de profs destinés à des profs en vrai
mais on va quand même la regarder
qu'elle est l'astuce c'est peut-être ça
marche avec les stylos excuse moi mais
je préfère aller au supermarché ou en
acheter un nouveau
je pense que personne ne nous en voudra
non c'est non c'est que moi moi attendez
attendez je retire ce que j'ai à dire je
retiens avant/après abusé en vrai ça
vaut entière dans le coup je retiens ce
que j'ai dit tout ce qui était en train
d'aller acheter un nouveau marqueur la
stoppe fait ça à champ de cannabis dans
un champ de maïs non
le plan était parfait jusqu'à
l'invention des satellites ccha au big
up à toute la prison la vitesse de ce
petit crabe poids j'ai rien sous-estimé
de plus qu'un crabe en fait mes mecs ses
pointes et calories qui doit brûler
quand il fait ça en vrai la 15 mètres
plus loin il est mort de faim sa vie
s'est terminée au vieux sli il s'agit
d'un père qu'est ce qu'il a fait
[Musique]
quoi la souplesse de set up bataille l'a
fait exprès non mais il a rien sauver du
tout il a essayé de kidnapper cet enfant
lui même sa chute n'a aucun sens s'il
est capable de tomber si bien c'est
qu'il a fait exprès tomber c'est pas
possible autrement
j'adore ça les zones où les nuages sont
bas j'adore de ouf
alors lui par contre il veut du mal
soyons honnêtes il créé une tempête mais
sur 20 mètres carrés où nous situer dans
ses vingt mètres carrés tués - o
ce gars récupérer un chien très mal
monnaie et la transformer en magnifique
le ski o
ah ah ah ah j'en ai déjà parlé mais les
vidéos de dodo sont celles qui me font
le plus pleurer au monde les gars c'est
terrible c'est des vidéos en fait c'est
des associations à qui on a signalé un
animal abandonné quoi abandonné souvent
depuis un bon moment donc en très
mauvais état et ils vont le récupérer il
le soigne il y trouve une famille et
c'est trop trop émouvant gens rien ne me
fait plus pleurer que ça allait bien ça
parle de tout p to p le toupet je dis
pas que je suis concernée par cette
vidéo mais en tout cas je pense qu'elle
va aider beaucoup d'entre vous quoi
[ __ ] ils dégagent qui lui reste de
cheveux il sait ce qui va t'en ai lu que
la [ __ ] de toupet oh la vache
à part le résultat est sûrs poids à
excuser moi je reviens je veux faire
poser un toupet le after il est
incroyable franchement mais bon t'as mis
de l'aclu sur le crâne quoi ce fait
chier grave ça me fait penser au voyage
de chihiro moi c'est sublime je suis
choqué c'est sublime
on dirait que c'est faux tellement c'est
beau bon après la photo le gala ouais
les petites étoiles machin j'ai mis mon
diaf à 3.4 et l'exposent demi sur 2.8 et
au tu vas acheter un kodak comme tout le
monde ne tuera pas le cas c est cool a
alors apparemment c'est à chongqing en
chine
ça fait en bien franchement ça fait
vachement envie moi un fémur de
dinosaure de 500 kilos découverts en
eaux la baguette du bellay et les
dinosaures incroyable savaient qu'ils
ont existé je sais pas pourquoi dans mon
inconscient ces genres un fantasme de
l'humanité l'existence des dinosaures
mais non en prison vraiment existé c'est
peut-être le plus beau tamla parce que
j'ai vu de ma vie
on va te dire
oui le ciel de paris c'est bon aux
comores avec scoliose en 5 secondes
l'es1 carapuce arrête un peu veut pas
devoir danser frérot va devoir gagner
des combats c'est pas pareil attends
attends attends couet on a un mec qui
fait donc du parapente ou là peut-être
un moteur dans le dos mais il le faire
défection noises aux effets des petites
sorties avec son incroyable regarder il
emmène son oiseau en balade
tranquillement c'est incroyable le mec
est tellement investi il a décidé
d'apprendre à voler pour pouvoir faire
des sorties avec son réseau c'est bon
les gars c'est bon on peut arrêter là on
tient l'anecdote qu'on va raconter à
notre entourage cette semaine est ce
qu'à un mec a pris une photo de lui tous
les jours pendant huit ans en plus il a
commencé jeune il a dû voir il a dû se
voir vieillir enfin devenir adulte c'est
trop cool je suis jaloux des gens qui
ont réussi à faire ça et aussi de ceux
qui ont fait une vidéo il ya genre 10
ans où il se pose des questions à eux
mêmes et ils y répondent dix ans après
je trouve ça incroyable ce truc de long
terme jordi pensait dix ans après lui
c'est pareil huit ans il a tenu ces
housses d'ailleurs il ya un site j'ai
oublié le nom qui permet de s'envoyer
des mails à un moment choisi par exemple
là je peux écrire un mail et choisir de
le recevoir dans trois ans sur ma boite
mail et dans trois ans je vais me levais
je verrai un mail de moi même j'aurais
probablement oublié que je m'étais écrit
ça ya trois ans et dans lequel je me
parle au mois du futur c'est ouf
bon c'est rôle dans le tableau de huit
ans et mon frère on se désole c'est j'ai
eu le temps d'expliquer un truc super
lot eroglu s'était pas fini bon eh bien
écoutez je taxe sur les dites vous a plu
moi je me sens bien j'aime bien regarder
des trucs comme ça ça me fait du bien je
vous dis à bientôt dans une prochaine
vidéo pas les dernières de l'année c'est
bientôt les fêtes alors ça en est où les
cadeaux apte à petit coup de pression à
jeter dans la mer - faut que je me mette
la peau vraiment j m bonne chance à tous
à bientôt quinze secondes
[Musique]